Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu UKW, unsere kleine Welt. Mein Name ist Tim Pritler und ich begrüße alle zur fünfzigsten Ausgabe auf diesem Kanal.
Hätte ich mir Anfang dieses Jahres auch nicht träumen lassen, dass ich schon vor Weihnachten,
hier mit fünfzig Sendungen am Start bin, aber das liegt daran, weil ja Corona ist und wir das Corona Regly gestartet haben, nämlich mit Pavel, hallo Pavel.
So haben wir hier auch so eigene Jubiläum. Heute ist der elfte Dezember zwanzig zwanzig.
Ja und wir könnten uns jetzt auch umbenennen in Talk Your Soul oder so.
Leider.
Leider haben wir wieder mit allem Recht behalten.
Vielleicht auch erfreulich, weil wenn wir jetzt gleich noch,
ausführlich darlegen jetzt einiges ins Rollen kommen, wo ich mir vor ein paar Wochen noch nicht ganz so sicher,
war, ob's wirklich ins Rollen kommen würde, auch wenn wir gesagt haben, dass es ganz gut wäre, wenn es ins Rollen kommen würde.
Ja, wir haben sogar gesagt, dass es früher oder später.
Unvermeidlich sein wird. Also wir hatten sogar gesagt, also kurz vor Weihnachten eigentlich wird es wahrscheinlich unangenehm und ja das.
Es passt.
Weihnachten wird ungemütlich, hieß eine Sendung. Es ist jetzt schon eine Weile her. Ich weiß grade gar nicht, welche das überhaupt war. Aber das war nicht letzte Woche.
Guck grad mal, weil es jetzt auch schon unsere unsere sechsundzwanzigste Folge, ne, die wir haben. Genau, am dritten Oktober haben wir das gesagt.
Ja jetzt sind wir wieder zusammengekommen und das heißt für uns erstmal wieder Zahlen zusammenfegen. Schauen wir doch erstmal, wie sich die Ist-Situation so.
Entwickelt hat. Pavel, was gibt's zu berichten aus der Zahlenwelt.
Ja, nachdem wir uns jetzt so die letzten vier Wochen mehr oder weniger seitwärts bewegt haben, also,
Letztlich Zeit verloren haben, also Infektionen nicht wesentlich reduziert worden sind. Ja, geht's jetzt seit einer Woche wieder steil bergab.
Und deswegen hatten wir heute auch neue,
bei den Neuinfektionen, also fast dreißigtausend.
Wurden heute gemeldet, neunundzwanzig, achthundertfünfundsiebzig.
Und auch leider äh neue Höchstwerte bei den gemeldeten Toten. Fünfhundertachtundneunzig, also fast sechshundert und äh weil die Werte schwanken halt ziemlich stark, aber selbst im sieben Tage Schnitt.
Haben wir halt zwanzigtausend Neuinfektionen pro Tag.
Und äh vierhundert Tote pro Tag im Durchschnitt. So, was halt.
Auf ja fast dreitausend pro Woche sind und das ist natürlich ziemlich heftig,
Und ja, konsequenterweise ist der sieben Tage R auch jetzt seit einer Woche über eins und steigt halt weiter aktuell,
für ganz Deutschland, je nachdem wie man interpoliert zwischen eins Komma null fünf und eins Komma eins DR Wert.
Gerade wenn man in die Breite guckt, war es ja eine Zeit lang so, dass,
Hälfte der Bundesländer steigende und die Hälfte der Bundesländer fallende Zahlen hatte, jetzt steigt's wieder praktisch überall und alle Bundesländer sind wieder über fünfzig,
neue Infektionen pro hunderttausend.
Und letztlich sind es Sachsen, Thüringen, Bayern, Berlin, Saarland und Baden-Württemberg, die schlimmer sind als der Bundesdurchschnit.
Und äh am meisten waren Saarland und Thüringen, äh wo die Zahlen zugenommen haben mit ungefähr vierzig Prozent Zuwachs in den letzten sieben Tagen gegenüber.
In sieben Tagen davor. Ja und.
Auch wieder beim Blick ja in die Top dreißig, die wir immer machen. Äh so wie verteilt sich das jetzt also verteilen sich die.
Herde, es sind neunmal Sachsen, siebenmal Thüringen, viermal Bayern, drei Mal Brandenburg, dreimal Baden-Württemberg, zweimal Rheinland-Pfalz und einmal Berlin.
So an Landkreisen in den Top dreißig und ja so in.
Top dreißig die sieben Tage Instinzen meistens zwischen dreihundert und sechshundert pro hunderttausend Einwohner und Spitzenreiter ist jetzt das bayrische Regen mit sechshundertvierundzwanzig auf hunderttausend.
Einwohner.
Dann stellt sich natürlich immer die Frage auch, okay, wie sehr sind jetzt diese Zahlen durch das Testregime beeinflusst? Wir hatten ja die Änderungen.
Fast zeitgleich mit der Einführung ja der neuen Maßnahmen der des Logdowns light,
wurde dann auch unglücklicherweise das Testregime geändert, weil die Testkapazitäten äh am Ende waren und.
Jetzt wird halt deutlich weniger getestet und in den letzten vier Wochen hat man auch sehen.
Das Testregime ähm.
Zu geführt, dass Neue, dass die Tests äh.
Genommen haben, also seit ja seit einem Monat jetzt fünf Wochen sogar.
Wurden jede Woche weniger Tests durchgeführt. Es hat sich zwar inzwischen stabilisiert, aber sagen wir sind auf einem,
neuen Tiefststand bei der Anzahl der durchgeführten PCR-Tests, also.
Ja zuletzt wurden in der KW zweiundvierzig, also es sind vor zwei Monaten wurden weniger Tests durchgeführt als in der letzten Woche.
Und ja also dann sagen die Anstiege sind real so, weil die.
Zahl der Tests ist nämlich zurückgegangen und die Zahl der positiven Tests ist gestiegen. So was heißt, dass wir ungefähr ja.
Über neun Prozent höhere positiven Quote haben jetzt bei zehn Komma zwei fünf Prozent liegt also es war ja mal so, dass wenn man sich hat testen lassen die Wahrscheinlichkeit.
Doch sehr gering war. Ähm also die unsere niedrigste positiven Quote, die wir hatten, waren null Komma fünf neun.
Prozent.
Das war im Sommer, das heißt so jeder ja übern Daumen zweihundertste wurde positiv getestet. Jetzt wird aktuell mehr als jeder Zehnte.
Positiv getestet.
Das heißt am Testen liegt.
Nicht, dass die Zahlen steigen, sondern die Tests gehen runter.
Und wahrscheinlich steigen die Infektionen sogar etwas stärker als das in den Zahlen jetzt sich wiederfin.
Und ja, ich fand das immer ein bisschen merkwürdig, weil ich dachte immer, das.
Immer erzählt, wie wichtig testen ist oder als Entscheidungsgrundlage, wenigstens, wenn nicht schon nicht zur Bekämpfung und es hieß doch auch immer, wir würden so viel testen in Deutschland, kannst dich nicht auch daran erinnern, dass.
War immer das Mann treu ja.
Ja. Aber wenn man das mal jetzt sich anschaut, wie sich das entwickelt.
Hat äh dann sieht man, dass wir jetzt ja ziemlich weit.
Sind also am drittwenigsten sogar im Ländervergleich jetzt mit unseren Nachbarn und anderen europäischen Ländern. Dänemark macht sechs Mal so viel Tests.
United Kindomacht und Schweden machen fast doppelt so viel Tests.
So die einzigen, die weniger getestet haben, geringfügig sind, Tschechien und Polen. So, praktisch alle anderen Länder äh testen mehr.
Wohlgemerkt jetzt auch umgerechnet auf die Bevölkerungsanzahl.
Ja genau, also klar, alles andere macht jetzt wenig.
Na ja, aber bevor es jetzt einer gleich wieder anzweifelt.
Mhm.
Wenn man dann auch guckt war das denn schon immer so? Stellt man fest, naja wir waren eigentlich nie Testweltmeister oder so oder vielleicht in den ersten Wochen
sondern eigentlich lagen wir eher immer im Mittelfeld und sind seitdem aber auch noch abgerutscht und.
Auch gleich nochmal auf der Vergleich mit den Positivquoten.
In anderen Ländern liegen. Da liegen wir jetzt so auf einer Ebene mit Italien und deutlich höher als Belgien, Frankreich oder UK.
Oder gar Dänemark oder Norwegen oder Finnland. Ähm ja, also da liegen wir halt auch ziemlich in der Mitte und äh,
sagt OK,
pro Einwohner wird hier jetzt auch nicht mehr, sondern demnächst sogar weniger getestet als in Italien und in den USA das äh entspricht jetzt nicht eigentlich den Selbstbild, was so immer,
Politik und RKI vermittelt äh äh haben irgendwie was tatsächlich stimmt ist, wenn man das jetzt äh so sagen.
Betrachtet so die kumulierte Zahl der Toten. Das ist das einzige, wo es, ich sage mal, noch okay.
Aussieht, aber vor im im Ländervergleich, im europäischen und äh mit den USA.
Aber alle anderen Indikatoren ja sind nicht gut so.
Auf jeden Fall hat es jetzt nicht lange gedauert, bis wir so unsere Todesgesamtzahl äh verdoppelt haben, so, ne? Und das. Und von daher und die Linie.
Geht ja auch weiter nach oben. Also das ist äh vollkommen klar, dass sich das in den nächsten vier Wochen nicht signifikant ändern wird, ne? Alte Regel, Leute, die in vier Wochen sterben, die äh haben sich unter Umständen bereits infiziert,
Von daher kann man auch jetzt bei den herzen Lokdownmaßnahmen werden gleich noch viel drüber sprechen. Äh davon ausgehen.
Dass das jetzt also mindestens noch zwei, drei Wochen mindestens auf diesem aktuellen Level äh sich halten wird, vermutlich eher sogar noch äh steigen wird.
Sich dann auf diesen gestiegenen Level noch hält, bevor es im günstigsten Fall überhaupt erst langsam wieder äh besser wird.
Und ich meine da es halt immer so zwei, drei Wochen äh hinter den Infektionszahlen hinterher läuft.
Wissen wir halt jetzt okay in den letzten drei Wochen war jetzt einigermaßen Plateau, wobei sich die Institenzen natürlich auch verlagert haben, hin zu den alten. Also insofern.
Sagen, wird sich der Anstieg jetzt erstmal abflachen, aber nicht wesentlich zurückgehen und wird dann wieder anziehen, weil die Infektionen wieder wieder anziehen. Das heißt, wir werden.
Wahrscheinlich auf dem ja auf einem noch einem etwas höheren Niveau als wir jetzt sind erstmal eine Weile verharren für zwei, drei Wochen bevor dann die Zahl der Toten nochmal anziehen wird.
Und wohin weiß keiner, aber kann sagen.
Ja, wir sind jetzt, was so die die Zahl der in den letzten sieben Tagen gestorbenen sind wir so, auf einer Ebene mit Schweden.
Und ja Frankreich und.
Und USA ist jetzt kein großer.
Abstand sage ich mal. Ähm ich meine, es ist also eher im Rahmen fast der Messgenauigkeit während.
Dänemark, Finnland und Norwegen es offenbar geschafft haben, also insbesondere Dänemark, wo die Infektion deutlich höher sind äh als bei uns. Sterben aber deutlich weniger Leute. Das ist auch irgendwie.
Unklar, warum das so ist. So, vermute mal, Dänemark hat es geschafft, irgendwie seine Alten besser zu schützen.
Das wollte ich auch gerade sagen, dass
Ist ja so ein bisschen der Schlüssel, wenn man sich eben anschaut, welchen Anteil, welche Jahrgänge jetzt an den gestorbenen Zahlen tatsächlich haben und da ist es halt einfach nach wie vor so achtzig plus ist einfach das, wo abgeräumt wird und das ist nicht schön,
Aber so ist es.
Ja, kleinen Blick noch auf Berlin jetzt. Also in Berlin äh gehen merkwürdige Dinge.
Vor sich, so zum einen gut ist Berlin häufig der Entwicklung ähm.
Den anderen Bundesländern so ein bisschen voraus. In dem Fall.
Ja äh saß in Berlin, in den letzten Wochen ein bisschen besser aus als im Bund, da sind schon die Zahlen wie etwas deutlicher zurückgegangen.
Also so extreme Schwankungen und Ausschläge so in den täglichen Berichten äh habe ich vorher noch nie gesehen.
Also da sind da sind Sprünge drin so, ja? Am Montag waren's dreihundert,
Neuinfektion. Heute tausendsechshundertzweiundfünfzig.
Also und das das macht natürlich, wenn man sich selbst über sieben Tage mittelt, so ähm.
Hüpfen dann äh die Werte alle wild hin und her, also ich glaube, da sind irgendwie Ämter, testen und so, das scheint alles nicht mehr so richtig zu funktionieren.
Vielleicht äh vielleicht sollte man mal ein vierzehn Tage R einführen.
Ja, ich fürchte im ich fürchte, weil einfach die.
Zahlen so verrauscht sind, haben wir langsam Probleme selbst mit wöchentlichen äh Zahlen oder mit sieben Tage äh Werten, weil die,
acht äh ja, aber ich meine, dass das eigentliche Problem ist, dass,
halt offensichtlich,
Tests irgendwo verschickt und gebunkert und dann alle plötzlich auf einmal eingegeben werden oder ja, ich weiß es nicht.
Also das war jetzt ein ganz ernst gemeinter Vorschlag, falls du zu wenig zu tun hast, wäre das vielleicht mal ganz interessant, mal so ein vierzehn Tage Wert äh mitlaufen zu lassen, der vielleicht den den Trend äh besser äh nachzeichnet, weil.
Kann man machen, der Nachteil immer natürlich ist, je größer man die Aktionsspanne wählt, umso mehr hinken die Zahlen so ein bisschen hinterher.
Aber einfach um so ein, so ein Bild zu bekommen für die Gesamtbewegung. Das ist natürlich dann im Nachgang auch ganz wertvoll, weil dieses Gehüpfe macht einen ja dann irgendwie auch ganz kurre.
Ähm die Zahl der Toten ist auch nicht ganz so stark angestiegen wie im Bund, muss man sagen in Berlin, näher. Aus welchen Gründen.
Immer, aber das dicke Ende kann natürlich noch kommen jetzt, wobei wir in Berlin.
So den den Gipfel so vor fast vier Wochen schon erreicht hatten und es äh seit dem.
Runtergegangen ist, aber jetzt auch in Berlin in den letzten Tagen wieder,
einen Anstieg so, aber wenn man sehen mit den, wie sagt man, mit diesen Ausschlägen, selbst bei sieben Tage Intapulation äh so.
Wird's, wird's echt problematisch, aber er wird äh übernimmt ungefähr bei eins Komma null vier,
im Bund irgendwo eher bei eins Komma null sechs oder eins Komma null acht, je nach Interpulationsmethode, also zwischen eins Komma null fünf und eins Komma eins liegt da im Bund, also ein bisschen
besser in Berlin, aber minimal.
Und in Berlin gucken wir uns ja auch öfter so die sieben Tage Instit an ähm nach Altersgruppen.
Und da hatten wir auch berichtet bis achtzig Plus äh ziemlich in die Höhe geschossen. Äh während.
Fünfzehn bis vierunddreißig, die halt bis zum Lokdown eigentlich dominiert haben, also bis ja vor knapp vier Wochen.
Hatten die die höchste Inzidenz von fast vierhundert, die sind jetzt wieder auf zweihundertfünfzig ungefähr runtergegangen.
Während aber jetzt die achtzig Plus hat ja bei um die vierhundertfünfzig pro hunderttausende Einwohnern stehen in Berlin.
Und alle anderen Altersgruppen äh sind unter zweihundert. Jetzt, weil ich.
Dann nochmal einen Blick ins Surfstud äh geworfen, weil leider die.
RKI, NPGO-Daten haben halt nur sechs Altersgruppen.
Und die sind alle so ein bisschen unschön und aus dem Surfstadt kriegt man zwar nicht die Daten von heute, aber äh immerhin die von letzter Woche.
In brauchbarer Form, also und auch nur wöchentliche Daten und da zeigt sich jetzt in den letzten zwei Wochen.
Dass auch bei achtzig plus ja die Institzen sich mehr als verdoppelt haben.
Und dass die zweithöchsten Institutionen,
interessanterweise bei den fünfzehn bis neunzehn Jährigen.
Zu finden sind in Berlin, also ja ähm Oberstufe und Lehrlinge.
Dass kann man sagen ist so seit.
In den letzten drei Wochen haben die die zwanzig bis vierundzwanzigjährigen überholt. Ja.
Ne? Also andere warten, jetzt kann man mittlerweile auch mit Fug und Recht sagen, äh die Schulen in Berlin und insbesondere.
Die fünfzehn bis Neunzehnjährigen, aber ja zehn bis vierzehn.
Auch nicht gerade niedrig sind, auch erhöht. Kann also mit Fug und Recht jetzt sagen.
Schulen in Berlin leisten ein deutlichen Beitrag.
Ja zur Ausbreitung der Infektion.
Lässt sich zumindest nicht groß anders erklären, ne? Ich meine, das ist äh wo sollen sie's denn sonst äh herholen.
Also es ist, ich meine, es ist völlig logisch, die müssen halt auch zur Schule hin, die müssen aus der Schule zurück und sitzen halt in der Schule mit ja, vielen Freunden zusammen und ob sie sich jetzt in der Schule anstecken,
oder nach der Schule spielt jetzt auch nicht die große Rolle, weil äh,
Ich mein wie willst du denn bitteschön jemanden klar machen, dass er zwar äh dass du zwar mit deinen Freunden stundenlang in einem,
Klassenzimmer abhängen darfst und die nach dem Unterricht nicht treffen.
Sollst? Ich mein das ist doch komplett lebensfremd.
Das funktioniert doch nicht.
Ja, dazu kommt natürlich jetzt auch der Faktor, also so sehr sich die Kinder auch an die Situation gewöhnt haben, das halt einfach nicht,
ne? Und die versuchen natürlich dann auch äh ihre ihre ausbleibenden Sozialkontakte auf die ein oder andere Art und Weise zu kompensieren. Und dann kommt's natürlich nach der Schule auch zu besuchen, wo dann klassenübergreifend oder äh auch mal Schulübergreifend
Äh man trifft sich auch nochmal mit jemanden aus der alten Schulklasse, nachdem man die Schule gewechselt hat, et cetera und dadurch
kommen natürlich dann auch immer wieder neue Brücken zum Vorschein, das lässt sich nicht verhindern, wenn es nicht komplett verhindert.
Wird, also wenn man nicht wirklich klar sagt, so jetzt bleiben mal alle zu Hause,
dann dann hast du diese Bewegung und dann ist das auch eigentlich keine große Überraschung und das ist natürlich auch insofern.
Schlimm, ne? Ich meine, man kann jetzt auch noch so vorsichtig sein, wie man will. Ne, also ich habe jetzt ja auch kaum.
Eigentlich gar keinen Außenkontakt so. Ich habe mich eigentlich völlig drauf eingefahren jetzt so, ich mache jetzt so meine Podcasts hier aus der Ferne und das werde ich halt jetzt bis Ende März so machen.
Das einfach so.
Aber du musst halt bei Androhung von Gefängnisstrafe dann doch deine Kinder in diesen Infektionsherd namens Schule schicken. So da kommst du kommst du in den Knast, wenn du das nicht.
Und die laufen dann äh die laufen dann halt die andere Hälfte des Tages äh die ganze Zeit um mich herum. So und äh ja, dann passieren halt Dinge, also es ist im Prinzip ist es so ein bisschen russisches Roulette.
Nee und ich meine ich mittlerweile bei jeder einzelnen Begegnung.
Mit Leuten, äh mit denen ich mich nicht regelmäßig treffe, sondern vielleicht einmal im Monat.
Oder oder alle paar Wochen. So habe ich die ganze Zeit so einen unbehagen dann und.
Äh sogar auch dann ja.
Zu Masken äh gegriffen und anderen Dingen. Das ist schon ein bisschen komisch, wenn man dann irgendwie einen Freund besucht und dann erstmal die Maske auspackt und dann ja, was nicht einfach gerade bei privaten,
treffen dann sich zu schützen und.
Da bin ich auch mittlerweile komplett schwerzbefreit. Also ich bin auch äh ich habe auch Upgrade äh gemacht von äh MNS auf FFP zwei Masken, also ich, wenn ich jetzt im Sup,
unterwegs bin, dann einfach nur noch mit elf FB zwei äh Maske, wo ich mir halt denke, so, ich habe jetzt schon genug unkalkulierbares Risiko
kann ich jetzt mal versuchen, das hier maximal einzuschränken. Ich habe auch ich meine am Anfang war waren wir, glaube ich, alle ja so ein bisschen würde ich sagen,
braucht es erstmal eine gewisse soziale Gewöhnung, ne? So Masten an sich,
Gott und wie sehe ich denn die aus? Und was denken die anderen über mich? So, mittlerweile ist mir das so scheißegal, was irgendjemand denkt, ja
so, das ist völlig egal, ich könnte jetzt auch im Overall äh rumlaufen mit Schutzbrille und äh durch den Supermarkt latschen und ich äh würde mir hin nicht mehr merkwürdig vorkommen. Obwohl ich in dem Moment wahrscheinlich wirklich aussehe wie ein Astronau.
Ja ja, nee, in der Öffentlichkeit, wie gesagt, sowieso kein Problem und bei, ich sage mal, offiziellen
Kontakten oder bei Geschichten wie, was weiß ich bei Ger,
Terminen oder so, klar, äh aber sagen beim beim Kumpel.
Mit dem im Zimmer sitzt äh irgendwo ähm ja das ist schon, ich meine dann manchmal komisch.
Ja, aber lieber komisch als Tod. Das ist das sollte man schon so sich zurechtlegen.
Was hat dich äh jetzt äh habe ich noch gehört nach dem Motto, oh, wie soll ich das denn meinen Kindern äh erklären, dass sie dieses Jahr äh die Oma zu Weihnachten nicht sehen können
Na ja, ähm,
ist vielleicht einfacher den Kindern das zu erklären, dass sie das dieses Jahr nicht sehen können als die nächsten Jahre zu erklären äh warum
Oma Weihnachten nicht dabei ist, weil wir nämlich irgendwie ja in dem einen Jahr sie besucht haben. So, als wir es vielleicht nicht hätten tun sollen. Hm.
Genau. Das ist einfach man verzichtet jetzt auf ein Weihnachten, damit man die Chance hat, noch ein paar andere zu haben. Ganz einfach. Jetzt sind wir schon beim Geigenhumor angekommen.
Ja
Soweit ist es schon.
Aber wir sind, glaube ich, auch mit den ganzen Zahlen jetzt durch, wenn ich das richtig sehe, ähm ja, wie gesagt, alles.
Nicht schön und ja.
Dann hast du ein bisschen Fernsehen geguckt und warst nicht so guter Laune.
Ja ich bin irgendwie durch laute Geräusche,
wie früher wach geworden, als ich wach werden wollte und.
Dann äh sah ich plötzlich äh jetzt live RKI Pressekonferenz äh auf einen meiner Devices äh aufpoppen. Hatte ich auch, das habe ich jetzt lange nicht mehr geguckt.
Das tue ich mir doch mal wieder an. So und ja es war wenig erbaulich. Es kam.
Es gab ein.
Paar Informationen, so die ja, ein bisschen fällt halt immer was dabei raus, aber wo ich mich dann wirklich echauffiert habe, war.
Als.
Dann eine Journalistin nach der äh Konferenz nach dem nach dem Vortrag ähm in Frage und Antwortteil dann die Frage stellte.
Erstmal ja, wenn denn ein harter Lokdown unausweichlich ist, wie ihn jetzt auch da.
Die Leopoldiner fordert warum macht man denn den nicht jetzt gleich und wartet noch bis Weihnachten. So.
Ja, äh natürlich gibt es da keine gute Antwort auf diese Frage, wenn man Wissenschaftler ist, so, da muss man sagen, na ja, äh eigentlich müssten wir in der Tat.
Es sofort tun, weil die Nacht auch.
Je früher, desto besser bei steigenden Zahlen, weil wenn wir jetzt noch zwei Wochen warten mit dem Logdown,
dauert der zwei Wochen länger, wenn die, wenn wir steigende Zahlen gerade haben, ja? Es ist ein ganz einfach,
So und daraufhin kam dann wirklich nur schwarfe Leih und Geschwurbel, so stat.
Irgendwie diese Frage zu beantworten, die ich fand ich sehr berechtigt war. So kam nichts und.
Damit konkret, also was, ich hab's jetzt, ich hab's jetzt nicht gesehen, aber was heißt Schwafelei, Schwub.
Äh ja äh völlig ja so so Tschubacker Verteidigungsmäßig, ja?
So erzählte über völlig andere Dinge auf einmal, wo sich der Zusammenhang auch überhaupt gar nicht zu der Frage erschloss,
so bis sagen völlig bis alle irgendwie einfach nur völlig verwirrt äh äh oder steht ja niemand, aber.
Was ist denn eigentlich schon Baggerverteidigung.
Äh Tschubakavata Bagger, die Fans äh nicht. Das ist, wenn nur irgendwie eine völlig.
Ähm abseitige,
logische Konstruktion macht, die mit dem Fall irgendwie gar nichts zu tun hat.
Ja? Oder mit dem mit der Frage um die es gerade geht aber äh und und dann hinterher sagen den Schluss ziehst und deswegen ist Tschubacker unschuldig.
So ähm ja
und alle nur verwirrt sind, aber du hast halt dein Ziel geschafft, äh dein dein Ziel erreicht, so alle sind verwirkt und,
mit ein bisschen Glück machen sie halt dann Fehler oder haben die Frage vergessen oder was auch immer
aber.
Okay, okay, das kommt aus Southpark, alles klar. Super Verteidigung.
Meiner angeblichen Damen und Herren geschworenen. Ich bitte Sie eine letzte Sache zu berücksichtigen
zeigt ein Bild von Trubaka. Dies ist Tschubacker, Tschubakka ist ein Wuki vom Planeten Kaschik. Aber Chubaca lebt auf dem Planeten Endoa. Denken sie darüber nach. Es ergibt keinen Sinn. Warum sollte ein Wookie ein zwei Meter großer Wookie auf Endo leben wollen? Zusammen mit einem Haufen winziger Evox
Es ergibt keinen Sinn. Aber was noch wichtiger ist, sie müssen sich ernsthaft fragen, was hat das mit diesem Fall zu tun? Gar nichts, meine Damen und Herren,
es hat nichts mit diesem Fall zu tun, es ergibt keinen Sinn, nichts von all dem, er gibt einen Sinn. Wenn Tschubacker auf Endor lebt, müssen sie ihn freisprechen. Das Plädoyer ist abgeschlossen.
Geht ab.
Okay und so äh ging dir das mit dem Herrn wieder.
Ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, plus äh das dann, ich meine auch andere Frage war dann, hm.
Er sei doch Chef,
so des wichtigsten deutschen Forschungsinstituts in Sachen Korona und ähm,
Wieso er denn jetzt äh lange bei dem offenen Brief
bei dem Leopoldiner Brief mitunterschreiben musste, ob er keine anderen Möglichkeiten hat,
mit der Bundesregierung zu kommunizieren. Gut, dann haben wir gesagt, ja, er hat andere Möglichkeiten und er
nutzt die auch ganz regel so, aber ja insgesamt.
So war da auch während der ganzen Pressekonferenz so null ähm verantwortungsgefühl oder,
Betroffenheit oder Bescheidenheit oder vielleicht.
Auch so der Hauch von hm möglicherweise haben wir jetzt nicht nachdrücklich genug der Politik vom Lokdown Light,
geraten, weil es hat ja nicht funktioniert. So aber
Äh ich mein klar ist es RKI nicht Schuld. Ich mein die in dem Sinne oder hat keine Hauptschuld sondern das war eine eine politische Geschichte aber so tatsächlich
bei dieser Pressekonferenz äh kam mir das eher vor, als seien es vielleicht nicht das ganze RKI, aber der
zumindest eher so ein so ein Regierungspressesprecher oder so und nicht
ja Mitglied eines Forschungsinstitutes gut,
wird vom Gesundheitsministerium finanziert und bezahlt ist also sozusagen schon eigentlich
Teil der Verwaltung und so, aber auf der anderen Seite.
Ja, es ist nicht nur irgendwie Teil davon. Ich meine, es ist eine Bundesoberbehörde, es ist jetzt nicht im eigentlichen Sinne ein Forschungsinstitut. Ja, da wird sicherlich auch Forschung gemacht, aber das ist halt primär, es ist halt einfach, dass übergeordnete ähm,
bürokratische Element, was halt alle Gesundheitsämter und damit verbundenen,
Institutionen zusammenfasst, muss man auch sehen. Also er ist schon mehr Teil der Politik letzten Endes als dass es sich jetzt hierbei um ein freies Institut handelt.
Na ja, also eigentlich sind sind halt ganz, ganz viele äh ja ähm,
Ziele, Institutionen oder Institute, sage ich mal, auf ähnlicher Weise an Ministerien aufgehängt, was weiß ich, BSI oder so, die dann am am Innenministerium hängen oder so.
Und ähm ja aber äh wenn man dann in, in die Aufgaben.
Liste guckt ähm.
An die andere Seite, Seite ist immer, er ist Wissenschaftler, ja? Also ist jetzt kein Bürokrat oder kein, kein unbedingt Gesundheitsverwalter, sondern er ist ursprünglich, ich glaube, Tierarzt eigentlich, der im äh Bereich von Tiersäuchen.
Geforscht hat. Gut, der hat jetzt keine Professur, er hatte irgendwie eine eine Honorarprofessur, aber okay. Er scheint auf jeden Fall auch einen dekorierter Wissenschaftler zu sein, ja. Und,
weiß ich nicht,
eigentlich ja hat sein Wort in solchen Zeiten auch Gewicht und ich kenne halt auch,
genug Beamte jetzt, wo sie sich oder Staatssekretäre oder äh ja Berufsbeamte, die.
Da auch auch in der Öffentlichkeit ähm sich,
auch kritisch äußern und ich meine und Ministerien, der die ganze Regierung ist auch nicht leicht geschaltet, ja? Also da gibt's halt auch äh Unterschiede zwischen den Ministerien, jedenfalls. Also ich fand's halt
enttäuschend. So, ich fand's halt sehr enttäuschend.
Sichtlicher.
Und teilweise auch ja wie sehr, sehr ärgerlich,
Und du hattest erzählt auch noch, dass das war das andere Ding. Ich meine heute habe ich wieder zwei Stunden damit verbracht, wieder um äh ein technisches äh Problem.
Herumzuarbeiten beim beim Download der Daten für heute,
irgendwie ist die die NPGO API heute kaputt gewesen. Ich weiß nicht, ob sie wieder funktioniert, aber da kam halt jedenfalls nicht die kompletten Daten,
zurück, wenn man sie angefordert hat, sondern stattdessen äh stand dann da, ja, es kann sein, heute äh irgendwie, dass die Daten nicht komplett kommen äh,
so nutzt doch bitte hier das CS, diese CSV-Datei stattdessen ja,
Ich kann zwar auch CSV verarbeiten, allerdings hätte ich dann erwartet, dass vielleicht sie dafür sorgen, dass im CSV auch die gleichen Datentypen,
drin stehen,
Aber stattdessen war halt äh waren halt wieder zwei neue Datumsformate, die es noch nirgendwo gab bisher. In keinem äh Zusammenhang, sodass sich halt wieder Datumskonversionsroutinen ähm ja.
Mir einbauen, musste, damit er dieses spezifische.
CSV verarbeiten kann, was mich wieder zwei Stunden.
Kostet hat, weil ich natürlich erstmal dachte, der Fehler liegt vielleicht irgendwie bei mir, beziehungsweise.
Äh wird's ja besser und dann dauert halt auch der ganze Durchlauf um immer eine halbe Stunde, sodass wenn dann Spieler Fehler da ist, ich der sich teilweise erst nach einer halben Stunde zeigt. Also, wie gesagt, ich war jedenfalls ja technisch sagen.
Lässt auch vieles echt zu wünschen übrig, die könnten wirklich ein paar äh Entwickler und Softwareleute brauchen, meinst du nicht auch.
Ja, haben sie ja
probiert auch welche zu bekommen, also zumindest haben sie welche beantragt, insgesamt haben sie sich äh für achtundsechzig Stellen wohl beworben und davon sind ihnen irgendwie vier zugesagt worden und die waren, glaube ich, noch nicht mal alle unbedingt IT. Ich bin mir nicht so ganz sicher, äh wie viele der vier Stellen, die bewilligt wurden
jetzt tatsächlich auch in dieses Fach reinfallen, aber es ist natürlich klar, dass äh wenn so mit einem umgegangen wird, dass man dann sich auch nicht aufstellen kann. Also mir ist das ehrlich gesagt so ein Rätsel
es ist für Behörden nicht einfach, da diesen Prozess anzuschieben, bis dann mal solche,
Positionen wirklich neu ausgeschrieben werden und dann auch noch besetzt werden, ja? Müssen auch noch irgendwie äh ausreichend attraktiv sein, um dann eben auch entsprechende,
Leute für diese Stellen zu finden,
langer Prozess, nur warum der jetzt immer noch so schwierig ist und warum dann überhaupt am Ende die Entscheidung stehen kann, dass hier nicht.
Zumindest in einem in einer anderen Dimension nachgerüstet wird, das ist mir ehrlich gesagt ein ein Rätsel.
Tim Corona ist ja bald vorbei und dann hat sich das auch mit den Pandimien, weil dann haben wir erstmal wieder hundert Jahre Zeit, bis die nächste Pandimie.
Kommt. So da sollen sich dann andere mit beschäftigen, nur ja.
Deswegen können wir doch jetzt nicht irgendwie eine unnötig Stellen aufbauen, wenn Corona ja fast vorbei ist. Da können wir ja und und wir keine Pandimien mehr zu befürchten haben. In Zukunft oder.
Es ist doch einfach.
Unfassbar. Ja, also wir haben da so ein bisschen äh Mitleid, ja, mit dem RKI äh RKI als als als Opfer äh der Bürokratie.
Und als äh Spielball der Politik vielleicht auch und vielleicht äh sehen die sich auch alle gerade so ein bisschen in so einer Rolle, in die sie eigentlich nie kommen wollten.
Keine Frage, ne? Aber sorry, da seid ihr jetzt nun mal, dann dann müsst ihr irgendwie auch äh damit klarkommen und ähm.
Bereich öffentliche Ansprache. Ist jetzt eh nicht so ein deutsches Ding, ne?
Ordentlich nach außen zu kommunizieren, weiß ich nicht, lernt man in diesem Land, glaube ich, auch nicht so richtig. Na ja gut, aber wir wollen sie jetzt mal nicht hier äh durchgehend äh nur kritisieren, darum geht's ja gar nicht. Es geht aber auf jeden Fall darum, dass derzeit.
Dieser gesamte politische Prozess, der versucht, ähm auf irgendeine richtige Maßnahme oder ein richtiges,
von Maßnahmen hinzusteuern an allen Decken und Enden ganz schön rumeiert.
Und ja und.
Am Anfang in den ersten Monaten.
Ja eigentlich 'ne ganze Menge auch richtig gemacht wurde hab ich das Gefühl scheint,
auch das RKI einfach den Ball fallen gelassen äh zu haben irgendwann.
Er weiß nicht, wann es passiert ist, es muss irgendwann im Sommer äh gewesen sein oder so, aber spätestens als man halt im.
September nicht auf die steigenden Zahlen äh begonnen hat zu reagieren und hat man halt im im Oktober sind eigentlich schon die ganzen Fehler gemacht worden und da wir sagen.
Spielt auch das RKI aus meiner Sicht 'ne wichtige Rolle weil die halt offensichtlich Politik,
Öffentlichkeit nicht hinreichend genug beraten und informiert haben, äh dass dann anschließend die Politik auch,
ja die richtigen Entscheidungen getroffen habt. So und jetzt kommt halt alles ja.
Oder die Politik halt nicht richtig zugehört, das äh würde ich jetzt auch nicht ganz ausschließen wollen.
Damit kommen wir ja eigentlich jetzt auch auf die aktuelle Debatte, ja äh dürften ja alle mittlerweile mitbekommen haben, wir auch. Ähm der Lokdownlight ist.
Glaub ich jetzt offiziell als gescheitert abgebucht worden und die Zahlen steigen, wir haben's ja jetzt ausreichend präsentiert.
Die Frage ist, was macht man jetzt und es kam halt so, wie es alle eigentlich verhindern wollten,
auch, glaube ich, Angela Merkel das ja ursprünglich mal bezweckt hat mit dem
mit diesem Soften Lokdown ab November, da war so der Traum mit, das machen wir jetzt mal. Zwei Wochen und dann gucken wir nochmal und dann vielleicht vier Wochen und dann gucken wir nochmal und vielleicht ist dann schon wieder alles gut, damit wir alle schön Weihnachten feiern können
Das ist jetzt gescheitert. Und jetzt ist die Frage, was passiert. Mittlerweile geht's halt äh in einigen Bereichen richtig los. In Sachsen richtig krass und im Prinzip.
Sachsen sein Lokdown ja auch schon angekündigt, hier geht's also schon ab
nächster Woche, in drei Tagen, am vierzehnten zwölften, los, da schließen die Schulen und sie werden auch vor dem zehnten ersten,
nicht öffnen, also kommt da quasi so eine Phase von drei Wochen, wo die Schule komplett zu hat, oder? Warte mal, ich schau nochmal ganz kurz eins, zwei
vier Wochen sind es dann.
Vier Wochen Schulschließung und damit sind sie dann halt allen ein wenig davongelaufen und seitdem das angekündigt wurde, hat das so eine gewisse Eigendynamik bekommen, auch in Bayern liebäugelt man, glaube ich, damit. Ich bin mir jetzt gerade zu
Zeitpunkt der Aufnahmen dieser Sendung am Freitagabend nicht
hundertprozentig sicher, wer jetzt schon auf diesen Zug mit aufgesprungen ist oder nicht. Ähm ich denke, es wird eine.
Mixtour geben, nur das Problem ist natürlich jetzt mit der kurzfristigen Ansage, kann sich natürlich keine Schule so richtig drauf einstellen. Ist auch so eine Phase, wo sehr viele
Klassenarbeiten geschrieben werden und so weiter und so fort. Na ja und jetzt werden wir also vermutlich so 'ne Mischlösung sehen aus.
Hier und da werden die Läden dann äh.
Na ja, nach der nächsten Woche geschlossen werden und sie sparen sich die letzten paar Tage Weihnachten. Erst hieß es noch, wir machen den Lokdown
nach Weihnachten, wo dann auch alle gesagt haben, was ist denn das für ein Lokdown? Irgendwie,
Wir warten jetzt nochmal zwei Wochen bis noch schlimmer wird, obwohl wir jetzt gerade diskutieren, dass es ja eigentlich schon schlimm genug ist, sodass wir das was machen müssen
oder teilweise wird es am vierzehnten zwölften losgehen, das können wir einfach gerade, also ich kann das zumindest gerade aus dieser Position
heraus nicht beurteilen, aber irgendwie sowas wird kommen und was auch immer dann kommt, es wird mindestens bis zum zehnten Januar anhalten.
Ja, es gibt wohl am Sonntag irgendwie eine äh Schalte mit der Kanzlerin und den Ministerpräsidenten.
Ja, Zeit wird's.
Und äh ja, also ich nehme an Videokonferenz, aber ähm ja im äh in der Zeitung
irgendeinem Artikelstand schalte, fand ich äh auch noch äh ja auf jeden Fall offensichtlich telefonieren oder Video konferieren die Ministerpräsidenten am Sonntag nochmal mit der Kanzlerin und wahrscheinlich können wir dann.
Sonntagabend nochmal dann äh hören, was denn dann endgültig passiert.
Das ist also jetzt die versprochene Planungssicherheit und äh das äh ja Weihnachten in Familie und äh.
Wurde, ja. Immer gut, wir wussten's schon vorher nur ich es ist,
ist wirklich so ärgerlich. Wenn man bei echt vor.
Selbst im Oktober noch wer noch Zei,
Wesen einfach für zwei bis vier Wochen zuzumachen
dann werden wir jetzt wieder längst raus aus dem Lok down und die Zahlen werden deutlich niedriger und irgendwie tausende Menschen weniger wären gestorben,
So, aber ja.
Im Nachhinein ist immer einfach, ne? Ähm wenn wenn ich mich so ein bisschen versuche daran zu erinnern.
Wie so dies Gefühl in der Bevölkerung war. Ich meine, das ist ja auch so ein Effekt, den wir jetzt
lange Zeit begleitet haben. Am Anfang ging das sehr schnell. Es hat so zwei, drei Wochen gedauert, bis,
bei allen so richtig durchgesickert war, aber danach gab's ja so diesen Konsens so, okay, da ist jetzt die die unbekannte Gefahr, die über uns kommt und jetzt handeln wir mal ganz schnell und dann hat's ja auch äh relativ gut funktioniert.
Und natürlich hatte keiner so richtig mehr Bock drauf und natürlich haben alle sich so ein bisschen durch den Sommer getragen mit dem.
Ach, gut, dass das jetzt nicht noch schlimmer gekommen ist. So wollen wir das ja aber auch nie wieder haben.
Und damit war dann auch so ein wenig diese Erwartung verbunden, ne, das wird ja auch nicht so weit kommen, weil wir sind ja Deutschland und so weiter.
Man allerdings so. Und das sind immer Wohlpfeil.
Rückblicken zu sagen, man hätte ja schon können und so. Wir dürfen das jetzt glaube ich zumindest ein bisschen tun,
weil wir's damals auch schon gesagt haben, ne? Das das einfach die Zahlenentwicklung äh so ist, dass man eigentlich jetzt sofort reagieren müsste.
Ja und ich fand damals auch immer wir hatten es gab halt das Beispiel Israel,
Es gab halt bereits das Beispiel Tschechien, die halt äh so letztlich sechs Wochen vor uns in den Logdown äh gegangen.
Sind und auch erstmal mit einem auch wie wir erstmal mit einem soften Lokdown äh angefangen haben und dann halt weiter weiter nachgelegt haben bis wirklich komplett dicht war so und das war äh,
ja eigentlich absehbar. So, ähm dass.
Natürlich war auch absehbar oder klar, halt weniger hilft, weniger, ja? Und das auf jeden Fall selbst wenn.
Sagen ist ausreichend Wirkung gezeigt hätte, der.
Lockdownlight, ja? Wäre er trotzdem viel, viel, viel länger äh gewesen als als alles andere Plus
natürlich meine, die Abwägung haben wir damals auch gemacht, okay, es wird kälter, wir wissen nicht genau, wie sich das äh aus
wirkt aber wir wissen, dass es sich zumindest nicht positiv auswirkt, sondern dass der Virus sich in der Kälte länger auf Oberflächen äh hält und in der Luft äh auch,
länger infektiös äh bleibt und das alleine sind Faktoren, von denen man nicht nicht weiß.
Und trockenere Luft in den in den Räumen, die die Ausbreitung befördert.
Ja und halt mehr Aktivitäten überhaupt, also in in also weniger Möglichkeiten, sich draußen zu treffen, also ungemütlicher.
Draußen so all all die die Dinge und seit Beginn wurde dann auch ja vor der Welle im,
Herbst gewarnt. So war ja nicht so, dass nicht irgendwie äh immer wieder betont worden wäre, ja und dann im Herbst und im Winter, das wird ein Problem werden, ja,
aber äh als dann die Zahlen äh das schon angezeigt haben
ganz klar, dass sich dort ein Problem entwickelt. Äh trotzdem nochmal zwei Monate gewartet. Bei uns und dann mit einem Logdownlight reagiert.
Christian Drosten auf Zeit online. Ein Plan für den Herbst, fünfter August zwanzig zwanzig.
Also was ich eigentlich sagen wollte ist das klügste wäre vermutlich gewesen die Herbstferien zu nutzen, das ist natürlich insofern ein bisschen schwierig als dass die Herbstferien nicht einheitlich sind ne,
Trotz alledem selbst wenn man die vielleicht auch nur ja ist die Frage, ob
sozusagen Maßnahmen auf einzelne Bundesländer äh in Deutschland den entsprechenden äh Effekt gehabt hätten, wenn man die äh Ländergrenzen nicht schließen kann. Aber egal, am Ende äh wäre das auch nur so ein Nebenfaktor gewesen, da hätte man halt einen Zeitfall eben die Schule länger zumachen können
Ich verstehe, dass dass die Bevölkerung und da wollte ich vorhin darauf hinaus im Oktober noch nicht so weit war. Es ist auch immer so dieses, wenn du aus einer,
politischen Position heraus solche Maßnahmen durchsetzt wir haben halt nicht hier irgendwie.
Diktatur, wo sind einfach irgendwas angeordnet wird und dann findet das statt, sondern es gibt natürlich extrem viel
Backlash, so. Es gibt, das sehen wir halt schon auf der Bund, Länderebene, jeder Ministerpräsident, jede Ministerpräsidentin möchte natürlich immer das Beste fürs Land und was gerade mal so als das Beste angesehen wird, ist immer dieses Abwägen zwischen
Wirtschaft, Gesundheit, Wirtschaft, Gesundheit, ne, was ja, wie weit schon vielfach besprochen haben, beides miteinander zu tun hat.
Abgerechnet wird halt am Ende eurem Jahresende und jetzt kam natürlich auch so im Bereich jetzt Wirtschaft, oh die Chinesen werden discorona ja mit einem,
Wirtschaftswachstum von plus zwei Komma zwei Prozent abschließen, ja? Während äh,
wir mit irgendwie minus vier bis minus sechs Prozent oder so äh am Ende des Jahres dastehen werden, das heißt wirtschaftlich haben wir da jetzt auch nicht viel gekonnt, ja? Klar gibt's noch Länder, die,
wie schlechter dastehen, aber es sind dann auch oft Länder, die,
stark von Tourismusabhängig sind und äh also da muss man dann halt auch nach nach Branchen gucken und ja jedenfalls haben wir jetzt irgendwie nicht viel gekonnt äh muss man sagen in der,
zweiten Welle da. Vielleicht auch die, weil die erste Welle so na ja, wird da auch besser laufen können, aber irgendwie hat's dann ja doch geklappt. Äh dachte, naja, dann
Das kriegen wir schon irgendwie hin, hat ja beim ersten Mal auch geklappt. Nur dass man beim ersten Mal halt einfach auch alles zugemacht hat. Und die Learnings und die Beispiele waren da,
so, aber man,
halt gedacht, ja was richtig sagt, was in anderen Ländern passiert,
trifft uns ja nicht. Also wir haben ja irgendwie irgendwie ist der Virus bei uns anders und.
Ja aber nicht. Wenn man einen anderen Virus als die anderen Länder.
Gut, was jetzt auf jeden Fall die äh die Verschiebung in der deutschen Politik in der Debatte, in der gesellschaftlichen Debatte mit befördert, ist der bereits erwähnte,
offene Brief der Leopold Diner,
Da wird im Wesentlichen halt genau das gefordert, was äh wir jetzt hier schon auch
gesagt haben, also ab dem vierzehnten Dezember soll die Schulpflicht aufgehoben werden
Läden sollten spätestens ab dem vierundzwanzigsten zwölften dicht sein, das ist natürlich auch schon mal ein Kompromiss, ne? Weil wenn man das jetzt einfach aus rein wissenschaftlicher oder rein gesundheitspolitischer Perspektive formuliert, dann gibt's gar keinen Grund, warum jetzt irgendwie.
Die Läden nicht auch am vierzehnten zwölften dicht machen sollten, weil.
Umso länger es dauert und so weiter. Wir wiederholen uns. Ja, oder zumindest eben so ein Co-Horting einzuführen bei den Klassen und dass die
dass sie äh Klassen sich halt aufteilen sollen und
all solche Maßnahmen. Das steht da im Wesentlichen drin, von vielen Leuten unterzeichnet worden und wurde ja dann in einer recht
Aufsehen erregenden äh Rede von Angela Merkel im Bundestag dann auch nochmal klar vertreten. Das war vollkommen klar, dass sie sich hinter diese Forderung stellt, dass das ihr.
Ich glaube auch schon seit längerer Zeit ihre Grundüberzeugung. Es ist aber einfach nicht möglich war, ähm alle Bundesländer,
da mitzunehmen. So, weil der Widerstand einfach zu groß war, dass sie gesagt haben, so, nee, machen wir nicht, wird's teuer, bla, bla, bla,
und jetzt stehen wir halt da äh an diesem Punkt nun. Ja, das mit dem Aufteilen der Klassen.
Ist natürlich auch etwas, was äh dann auch im Januar natürlich äh eine Rolle spielen kann, weil zehnter Januar kann man halt jetzt sagen,
Wenn alles erst am vierundzwanzigsten zwölften wirklich richtig schließt und dann auch der der Weihnachtsrollover auch noch dazu kommt, dann ist halt am zehnten Januar noch überhaupt nichts besser,
Also ich meine, wenn wir Glück haben, kann man am zehnten Januar irgendwie eine Trendumkehr sehen. Bestenfalls, und zwar auch nicht genauer.
Als wir jetzt die Trendumkehr in diesem äh November-Lokdown gesehen haben, nämlich dass es sich zwar.
Irgendwie stabilisiert zunächst einmal, also die Zahlen nicht steigen oder nicht nicht mehr so stark steigen, aber keiner weiß, wie es weitergeht.
Und jetzt geht's halt äh derzeit gerade wieder hoch und genauso kann's halt am zehnten Januar auch sein. Das heißt, der ganze Spaß muss jetzt eigentlich insbesondere, wenn man wirklich erst ab dem vierundzwanzigsten zwölften,
dicht macht und noch den ganzen Weihnachtshummel und Weihnachtsmärkte und Glühwein ständen und was weiß ich, was da alles noch offen haben soll. Wenn das noch läuft, wenn Shoppingballs offen haben
alle ihren ganzen Weihnachtsverkauf äh noch durchziehen wollen, die Leute dann halt wie die Bekloppten reinrennen. Oh Gott, Gott ich brauche noch ein Geschenk und hier und weißt du, stundenla
durch irgendwelche Regale durchziehen, das ist sehr genau die Situation, die man eigentlich nicht haben will. Na ja wir sagen.
Ich habe starke Zweifel, dass wir am zehnten Januar in irgendeiner Form mit einer Institenz in Deutschland aufwarten können oder auch nur mit einer Trendumkehr, die so klar und deutlich ist, dass man sagen kann,
Och, das war aber jetzt ein schöner Lokdown über Weihnachten. Jetzt können wir wieder irgendwie äh weitermachen wie normal. Wird nicht so sein, also sehe ich einfach nicht.
Nee, also bis wir wieder unter die fünfzig kommen.
Braucht jetzt eine Weile. So zumal.
Ja das kommt jetzt drauf drauf an. Also man kann eigentlich nicht wirklich Vorhersagen machen. Das der größte Joke war.
Heute ist mir eine Mitteilung, wie der von irgendeinem Handelsverband äh so die.
Halt befürchten, dass im neuen Jahr äh ein.
Ewiger Lokdown oder Logdown Light stattfindet und alle.
Pleite gehen jetzt, weil irgendwie zu befürchten ist, dass wir ja so schnell nicht lockern können, ja? Also das, da muss ich sagen,
das hat
das schlägt dem Fass eigentlich den Boden aus, weil gerade sagen der Handel war ja diejenigen, die sich gegen jede kleinste Einschränkung äh äh immer gesperrt haben, ja,
so erinnerst dich wie als es darum ging äh die Zahl der.
Kunden zu begrenzen in Supermärkten und so, was das für ein Aufstand.
Und man dann sogar noch ein Kompromiss gemacht hat, ja, das in kleinen Läden dann mehr Leute rein dürfen,
mit irgendwie einer pro zehn Quadratmeter statt wie man wollte irgendwie einer pro zwanzig oder fünfundzwanzig weiß ich nicht ja und.
Das ist dann auch passiert, ja? Und jetzt heulen sie rum, äh, dass,
dazu führt oder dass ja, dass alles dazu geführt hat, dass es jetzt,
absehbare Zeit einfach nicht gut laufen wird mit dem Handel, ja? Wir haben sich also meiner Meinung nach komplett ins Knie geschossen.
Aber sehen das natürlich auch nicht ein. Dass das ihre Mitschuld ist, dass wir in der Situation sind, wie wir sind.
Ja mit Schuld ist das immer schwieriges Wort, ne? Also Schuld äh will ich jetzt gar nicht mal aufbringen, aber
sie haben ja auf jeden Fall eine Rolle gespielt, sagen wir es mal so und ähm es ändert ja nichts. Also ich meine äh wenn man's halt nicht macht, dann dann wird's halt wieder nicht besser und dann ist es danach noch schlimmer. Ich meine, diese Lehre haben wir jetzt wirklich zwanzig Mal durch. Ja, also,
Wir sind jetzt an dem Punkt, wo wir einfach einen harten Lokdun brauchen. Wir werden ihn auch kriegen. Die Diskussion ist nur ab wann
wenn wir ihn haben, wenn wir ihn am vierzehnten haben, werden wir ab dem einundzwanzigsten haben oder erst am vierundzwanzigsten ich vermute mal, wir werden.
Ist mein Tipp ist so ein bisschen der einundzwanzigste, man opfert noch so die letzten zwei, drei Tage, auch gerade im Hinblick auf äh die wahrscheinlich unvermeidlichen
Familien zusammenführung, die trotzdem stattfinden werden, auch wenn sie eigentlich verboten sind
Ja, also es machen wir uns nichts vor. Viele werden sich dem einfach wieder setzen, weil sie denken, ach na ja, die anderen sind ja alle krank, aber ich ja nicht. So und dann.
Tickt eigentlich,
Die Uhr sagen wir mal so ab dem zwanzigsten, einundzwanzigsten los, so. Dann haben wir also,
erste Woche wirklich 'ne,
ein Rückgang oder die Chance auf einen Rückgang
Das wird sich also dann nach zwei Wochen das erste Mal zeigen können, dann haben wir irgendwie den vierten Januar und dann eine Woche später ist halt einfach noch nicht so viel passiert. Und
Deswegen sage ich halt, dass der Spaß.
Einschränkungen wird es auf jeden Fall geben bis Ende Januar. Ob die jetzt diese Signatur harter Lokdown und alles es geschlossen haben, weiß ich nicht. Keine Ahnung. Werden wir sehen, ne? Aber.
Ich kann jetzt allen, die hier nur zuhören und vielleicht so ein bisschen von uns auch eine Einschätzung, hm, erwarten.
Sagen ich denke.
Nehmt euch nichts vor. So, macht keine Pläne für den Januar. So, das ist einfach nicht gut.
Das andere Problem, was noch äh jetzt reinspielt ist, das hatten wir auch vor zwei Sendungen äh glaube ich mal.
Beleuchtet nämlich ähm dass ja auch Maßnahmen.
Mit der Zeit an Wirkung verlieren, dass ich sagen Maßnahmen auch totlaufen oder umgangen werden oder das zeigt es halt auch, dass sagen bei vielen Maßnahmen,
nach vier Wochen die maximale Wirkung erreicht ist und dass dann äh ja die Maßnahmen an Wirksamkeit verlieren,
so und das zweite Problem ist, dass halt beim Aufheben von Maßnahmen in der Regel.
Die Infektion stärker ansteigen als sie beim Einführen der Maßnahmen reduziert wurden. Das heißt eigentlich.
Was man in der Situation, wenn man schon einen Lokdown braucht, dann will man einen maximal harten Lokdown.
Der nicht länger als vier Wochen,
dauerhaft so, dass es einfach das effektivste, weil in dem Moment, wenn du so einen halben Logdown machst, äh ja und jetzt sind wir sechs Wochen im Logdown und jetzt sehen wir's halt auch wie das verpufft,
so weil die also es ist ja nicht so, dass irgendwie gelockert worden wäre und trotzdem gehen die Zahlen hoch, trotz obwohl wir im Lokdown sind, da sind wahrscheinlich genau.
Effekte, die da jetzt eintreten und,
insofern kann das jetzt auch sein, wenn jetzt nochmal draufgelegt wird, dass ja,
die Wirksamkeit sagen doch wie er nicht ausreichen wir jetzt drauflegen, wenn wir Pech haben
äh schaffen wir wieder nur ähm die Infektion auf einem höheren Niveau zum Stillstand zu bringen, auf dem wir dann äh bis auf absehbare Zeit verharren. Ich glaube nicht, dass das so
kommen wird. Ich denke äh wir werden's runterkriegen, aber auch wenn man auf.
Andere Länder schaut, sieht man halt den Effekt auch, dass der Lokdown irgendwann an Wirkung ein,
und ja die zahlen dann einfach nicht mehr weiter runtergehen, sonder,
auf einem Niveau verharren, das sehen wir im Moment in Tschechien
Das sehen wir im Moment in der Slowakei und das Schicksal könnte uns halt auch äh bevorstehen,
selbst der harte Lokdown, weil wir jetzt sozusagen unser Pulver verschossen haben, so halb äh nicht mehr das bringt, was er gebracht hätte, wenn wir von Anfang an,
einen harten Lokdown gemacht werden. Aber hoffen wir mal über den Teufel nicht allzu sehr an die Wand, aber es ist mein.
Es gibt nur eine Richtung äh im Moment so, also nämlich in Richtung äh härterer Lokdown.
Ich hab's ja persönlich nicht so mit Weihnachten, deswegen tut mir das persönlich nicht so weh,
wie auch immer blicken wir mal äh etwas in die andere Zukunft und äh ich möchte an dieser Stelle nochmal auf Impfstoffe zurückkommen. Da hat sich ein bisschen was getan. Ähm,
Zunächst einmal äh kurze Korrektur. Ich glaube, ich habe letztes Mal gesagt, dass in United Kingdom,
sowohl der Moderner als auch der Biontech äh Pfeiser ähm Impfstoff zugelassen wurden, dem ist nicht so, es handelt sich nur um den von Biontech und der wird jetzt auch schon,
geimpft. In der Zwischenzeit hat auch Baran und äh auch die USA,
dem Impfstoff durchgewunken, also das sind alles diese Notfallzulassung oder keine Ahnung wie der hier Regelungen bei rein ist, aber manche konnten's halt einfach nicht so richtig erwarten und haben sich wohl entsprechende Kontingente gesichert und äh.
Vergeben den jetzt auch,
Den Impfstoff müssen wir erstmal gucken, das wird jetzt auf jeden Fall nochmal zwei Wochen dauern bis äh man da überhaupt erste Effekte sehen kann.
Und natürlich, wie schon angekündigt, wenn erstmal ältere Leute und Leute aus dem Gesundheitssystem geimpft, aber die Mengen, die jetzt hier abgegeben werden, die sind noch sehr überschaubar.
Apropos hast du es mitgekriegt eigentlich mit der Debatte oder kontroverse in den USA? Äh wegen dem Impfstoff.
Welche Kontroverse, die haben ja eine Menge davon.
Ja ja, na ja, es ging äh darum, dass Pfaiser, glaube ich, den USA vor ein paar Monaten die Möglichkeit gegeben hat, ähm sagen mehr Dosen.
Zu kaufen, ja ja, das haben sie ja nicht gemacht. Das ist halt die Trump-Regierung, also.
Was sie dann nicht gemacht haben
und äh ja jetzt äh Daten sagen, es hieß ja, aber bevor nicht
alle Amerikaner irgendwie genug Impfstoff haben, bleibt der Impfstoff im Land, ja, wird nichts exportiert. Erst müssen irgendwie die Amerikaner geimpft werden, bevor wir irgendwas von dem Impfstoff.
Ja, das ist so wieder so eine,
die äh Trump unterschrieben hat und äh alle Experten, die dann dazu befragt wurden, haben nur durch so etwas stumpf in die Kamera geguckt und haben gesagt, ja, sie wissen jetzt auch nicht, was das jetzt irgendwie ändern soll, weil das
gar nicht und das ist ja nicht ihrer und äh also.
Ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja. Ja, also.
Ich wollte jetzt mal so einen kurzen Überblick äh äh geben, was eigentlich sonst noch so passiert ist.
Vielleicht äh weil das jetzt auch langsam ein bisschen unübersichtlich wird, nochmal eine Übersicht von allen Impfstoffen, die derzeit überhaupt in äh naher Zukunft Verfügbarkeit haben
können. Also, da haben wir natürlich jetzt den äh diese MRNA Impfstoffe von.
Also das Ding, was hier in Deutschland entwickelt wurde, dann den von moderner, der in den USA entwickelt wurden, die haben halt jetzt alle ihre Phase drei durch und das sind so die ersten, die jetzt überhaupt an Start kommen
Dann hatten wir auch schon berichtet
die Entwicklung in Großbritannien von einer University of Oxford. Dieser auf äh diesem Schimpansen Adenovirus äh vektorbasierende Impfschoff, der.
Er hat seine Phase drei auch durch und dürfte demnächst dann auch äh seinen Weg in die Welt äh finden. Aber äh es gibt ja auch noch,
andere Entwicklungen
unter anderem ist ja auch noch in Deutschland einer in der Entwicklung von Kurwag, aber die sind halt erst in Phase zwei, das wird also noch ein bisschen dauern, also bleibe ich jetzt erstmal bei denen, die
Phase drei erreicht haben.
Ja, die Chinesen sind nämlich auch ganz kräftig unterwegs. Also da gibt's äh
das Unternehmen Sino wagt, dann gibt's ein,
aus äh Wuhan. Das sind jeweils so äh Impfstoffe auf Basis von inaktivierten,
Viren, dann gibt es natürlich den russischen äh Impfstoff, der hat jetzt seine Phase drei, auch abgeschlossen und da werden jetzt auch demnächst äh erste Impfungen wohl stattfinden.
Ähm dann gibt es noch einen weiteren äh aus.
China, der so ähnlich funktioniert wie der russische. Ich kann zu diesen,
chinesischen Impfstoffen gerade nicht so richtig sagen, wie abgeschlossen die sind meines Wissens befinden die sich alle gerade in Phase drei und werden so demnächst abgeschlossen
sein oder sind schon abgeschlossen? Keine Ahnung.
Ja und dann gibt's noch einen von ähm Johnson und Johnson aus Belgien, der wohl auch in Phase drei ist, äh bald noch dazukommen wird und es gibt noch in USA einen von der Firma,
Novawax, der auch noch dazu kommen soll. Also das ist sozusagen das, was demnächst alles auf uns zu äh rollen wird.
Also ich hatte nur gehört, dass die Chinesen schon seit Monaten in großem Maßstab impfen. Also sich in diesen schon viele Millionen äh Dosen verabreicht.
Ja, ich glaube, im Militär haben sie das irgendwie gemacht, also da äh das ist äh also ich habe jetzt zumindest noch nichts gesehen, wo die wirklich richtig ihre Ergebnisse schon komplett ähm veröffentlicht hätten.
Und ähm ich kann mich da auch irren, aber.
Ja. Also ich war meine gehört zu haben, dass die halt bestimmte äh Gegenden Gebiete Städte,
komplett durchgeimpft haben. Also es ist jetzt nicht so sagen nicht nach irgendwie Alter, sondern keine Ahnung hier,
zu viel davon und das ist zu wichtig diese Stadt deswegen impfen wir die jetzt alle durch.
So
Das muss man nochmal ein bisschen beobachten. Das wird sicherlich ganz interessant werden, wieder die Strategien sind, aber ich denke mal äh die chinesischen Impfstoffe, die werden wir hier in Europa erstmal so schnell nicht sehen, ähm weil die wahrscheinlich erstmal im Wesentlichen mit China beschäftigt sein werden.
Ja dann haben wir ja in Deutschland die.
Vorbereitung zumindest, also hatte ich ja schon gesagt, es wird hier,
ein äh eine Zulassung gegen Ende des Jahres vermutlich geben werden, nehme ich mal an, also auf europäischer Ebene, ne, die Briten sind ja vorgepirscht, der Rest hält sich quasi an den normalen Prozess
Deswegen gehe ich davon aus und es ist ja auch so, um wirklich effizient impfen zu können, musst du eben auch eine entsprechende Verteilungsstruktur haben. Und was jetzt
aktiv stattfindet, ist halt der Aufbau dieser Impfzentren.
Ne? Also ich glaube alleine in Berlin wird da an drei, vier oder fünf verschiedenen Locations gebaut,
Da gibt es also bestimmte Orte, äh wo Platz ist und dort werden eben so Impfzentren aufgebaut, das wird also quasi so vorm Skretch.
Aufgebaut, sodass dann eben, wenn das alles voll im Betrieb ist, ähm alles in Angriff genommen wird.
Der Klima, den ich kenne, der ist da auch mit beschäftigt, da überall Internet reinzukriegen, weil das ist ja irgendwie auch wichtig,
Von daher äh weiß er es auch so genau, dass die Dinger jetzt wirklich aufgebaut werden, sodass es also hier so im Januar wahrscheinlich losgehen wird mit dem Ganzen.
Die Zulassung in USA hat dann noch diesen schönen Nebeneffekt, dass er nochmal ein längeres Dokument veröffentlicht wurde, in Bezug auf diesen Biontech-Impfstoff.
Ähm die hatten also jetzt am zehnten Dezember ein äh Comity Meeting und da haben sie alle abgestimmt und haben gesagt, okay
der Impfstoff darf in USA eingesetzt werden, äh das nennt sich da Emergence Use Außerization, EUA, also im Prinzip sind Notfallzulassung
und ja in dem äh Rahmen haben die dann eben,
alles nochmal diskutiert und dann darüber abgestimmt und es ging, glaube ich, irgendwie so siebzehn zu vier oder irgendwie sowas aus.
Keine Ahnung was da äh noch eingewendet wurde von einzelnen auf jeden Fall klare Mehrheit dafür diese Zulassung durchzuführen und dann ist halt auch noch ein entsprechendes Pepper veröffentlicht werden worden wo eben diese ganzen.
Zahlen drin stehen, also diese konkreten Unterlagen, die vorgelegt wurden.
Ja, da habe ich jetzt so ein bisschen na ja reingeschaut, ist fast schon ein bisschen übertrieben, weil es gab da so eine interessante Grafik zu sehen und ist ja immer so schön, wenn man eine hübsche Grafik hat zum angucken, muss man sich ja die ganzen Details nicht durchlesen. Aber,
was da halt doch relativ klar äh ist. Nach Verabreichung der ersten Dosis.
Und äh zur Erinnerung geplant ist, man kriegt eine erste Impfdosis und danach kriegt man nach drei Wochen bei manchen Impfstoffen nach vier Wochen zweite Dosis.
Um die volle Wirksamkeit zu erzielen. Und äh nach äh Verabreichung der ersten Dosis,
aber in den ganzen Untersuchungsdaten schon relativ klar zu sehen, dass diese Impfstoffe schon nach zwei Wochen wirken.
Also schon die erste Dosis wird vermutlich eine Wirkung haben. Das sind eigentlich sehr gute Nachrichten.
Weil bisher hieß es ja immer, es dauert zwei Wochen, aber eben zwei Wochen nach der zweiten Dosis. Ne, also dass man sich eigentlich nach sechs Wochen erst so richtig sicher sein kann.
Diese Daten legen zumindest nahe, dass schwere Krankheitsverläufe oder überhaupt ein ein Krankheitsbeginn ein echter
im Idealfall zumindest nach zwei Wochen schon äh verhindert werden kann in den allermeisten Fällen,
Das finde ich ganz praktisch. Allerdings hat es in US äh in in äh United Kinglem hat es auch Probleme gegeben und zwar,
gab es bei zwei.
Leuten, denen der Impfstoff verabreicht wurde, starke allergische äh Reaktionen, also bei Leuten, die halt irgendwie als Allergiker gelten, keine Ahnung.
Gegen was die allergisch waren, das weiß ich nicht
da kenne ich mich jetzt auch zu wenig aus, um das zu beurteilen, wie sowas zusammenhängt. Ich kann mir nur halt vorstellen
Man weiß ja, dass bei diesen MRN A Impfstoffen die eigentliche Reaktion, da hat sich glaube ich auch letzte Woche drüber erzählt, dass die eigentliche Reaktion auf den Impfstoff selber relativ stark ist. Also,
Schmerzen an der Einstichstelle, Fieber, ähm,
andere Sachen, die dann auch relativ schnell wieder verschwinden und für die meisten Leute auch kein Problem sind. Was.
Man vielleicht mal salopp einfach damit erklären kann, dass das Ding halt genau das tut, was auch auf der Box steht, nämlich es soll das Immunsystem aktivieren, ja? Das ist S,
der Sache und
Nebenwirkungen sind jetzt keine Nebenwirkungen im eigentlichen Sinne. Es sind eigentlich mehr oder weniger direkte Auswirkungen, weil man will ja das Immunsystem aktivieren und genau das ist halt das, was das Immunsystem in dem Moment macht. Es schlägt Alarm
Temperatur hoch, sagt hier ist irgendwas passiert, eindringling, Alarm, Alarm tut weh, das ist das, was ein Immunsystem tut und äh,
Ich vermute mal, dass es eben jetzt bei bestimmten Allergikern, die in irgendeiner Form auf solche Prozesse im Immunsystem besonders,
stark reagieren, dass die dann halt überdurchschnittliche allergische Reaktionen hatten,
Hat erstmal zur Folge, dass er eine starke Allergiker äh von der Impfung ausgenommen werden. Das muss man jetzt mal schauen, was dabei rauskommt. Ich persönlich würde da was jetzt kein,
negativen Schluss ziehen, dass es jetzt hier für irgendwas nicht geeignet ist.
Generell ist es auch ein guter Ratschlag, wenn man sich impfen lässt.
In den eins, zwei, drei Tagen nach der Impfung sich zu schonen,
Also es ist eine ganz schlechte Idee, sich eine Impfung abzuholen und dann weiß ich nicht, joggen äh äh zu gehen oder äh
vielleicht unmittelbar danach, ist jetzt nicht das Ding, aber es ist.
Schon so, also es ist auch bekannt, dass.
Wenn du geimpft wirst und nicht aufpasst, also dich dich dann nicht schonst, sondern Stress hast oder ähm,
ja äh also Stress und körperliche Anstrengung sollte man in den Tagen nach einer Impfung unbedingt vermeiden. So, also.
Die sich impfen lassen und dann in den Flieger steigen zum Beispiel oder so, ist äh irgendwo hinzufliegen oder auf auf äh keine Ahnung äh Betriebsreise oder Firmenreise,
zu gehen, äh Geschäftsreise zu gehen, ist keine gute Idee.
Wird abgeraten von.
Unbedingt abgeraten von man sollte dann nach Möglichkeit eben sich sein Leben auch so einrichten und timen, dass man halt ja in den Tagen nach der Impfung eigentlich nichts stressiges äh vorhat.
Ja, ansonsten ich sehe viel Optimismus.
Was so die langfristige Auswirkung der Impfstoffe betrifft. Jetzt muss man natürlich sehen,
Das mit Impfzentren muss funktionieren, das mit der Produktion muss gut anfahren, es kann natürlich immer noch sein, dass wir Probleme haben werden, dass einfach die Produktion stockt, weil.
Ne, die Materialien nicht in den Mengen oder in der Qualität verfügbar sind oder sich in irgendeiner Form andere Probleme oder Verteilungsprobleme äh ergeben.
Ist auf jeden Fall sehr optimistisch. Der hat gesagt, äh er geht davon aus, dass äh.
So gut wie alle Impfstoffe, die in Entwicklung sind, so im Februar am Start sein werden. Das sehe ich eine ziemlich bemerkenswerte äh Aussage.
Kann mir auch gut vorstellen, dass das dann irgendwann im nächsten Jahr plötzlich ganz schnell gehen äh wird, weil dann plötzlich weiß ich nicht, fünf, zehn Hersteller äh auch auf den Markt kommen und äh ja
dass man dann schon irgendein Impfstoff wird man schon abkriegen äh im Frühjahr denke ich mal.
Ja vor dem Sommer und ja nur.
Definitiv auch wenn es im Moment für Berlin waren jetzt die Zahl von erstmal zwanzigtausend Impfungen pro Tag.
Äh avisiert äh und.
Bei der Größe, ich meine, das ist schon mal was so, das sind schon mal ja.
Dass dann pro Monat sechshunderttausend Leute habe ich das richtig gerechnet ungefähr oder sechshunderttausend Dosen. Das heißt, selbst bei dieser Sankt geringen äh.
Zahl von zwanzigtausend, wenn sie denn erreicht,
wird würde es sowas fünf, sechs Monate dauern ungefähr Berlin durchzuimpfen, aber ich gehe mal davon aus, wenn man's schaffen sollte, das noch weiter zu verdoppeln.
Dann müsste eigentlich Berlin so sagen wir April oder Mai durchgeimpft sein.
Also ich habe da auch skeptischere Töne vernommen, was äh so die Zahl äh der äh Impfung betrifft, die tatsächlich machbar sind. Das,
ist glaube ich noch ein bisschen zu früh. Ich würde sagen, wir warten mal so ab, wie das im Januar anläuft und dann wird das äh auch alles noch sehr viel mehr in den Fokus rücken und dann wird auch klar sein
siehst du die Produktion verbessern? Ich würde mir am meisten Abhilfe dadurch versprechen, dass halt jetzt,
weitere Impfstoffe zugelassen werden, die dann vor allem auch noch andere Bereiche der Welt äh abdecken, weil,
klar, wir blicken natürlich hier primär auf Deutschland, aber letzten Endes muss das Problem global gelöst werden und das wird auf jeden Fall noch lange dauern, also ich denke mal, das wird schon noch ein Dauerthema in zwanzig einundzwanzig werden.
Auf der anderen Seite, ich glaub nie zuvor in der Geschichte der Menschheit wurde in so kurzer Zeit so viel
Geld und Hirnschmalz in die Entwicklung von Impfstoffen gegen
einen spezifischen Erreger, der auch nicht so stark montiert.
Klar, aber das ist ja eine, es ist ja, es ist ja nicht eine Frage der Qualität der Impfstoffe, sondern es ist jetzt sozusagen,
einfach eine schiere Frage von hast du genug Personal?
Brauchst einfach Leute, die die eine Spritze setzen können, du musst Leute kennen, die in diesem äh,
Prozess, den Transport und Dokumentationsprozess eingebunden sind. Alles nicht unmöglich, aber jetzt auch nicht so, dass du mal eben beim Arbeitsamt anrufst und sagst, wir brauchen jetzt mal fünfzigtausend Impfer.
So wie du dir irgendwie äh Leute zur Kartoffelernte holst, das ist äh.
Haben die nicht so einen Start-Track Device so, was dann an den Hals so nächste.
Schön wär's. Ja, nee, soweit sind wir leider nicht,
Andere gute Nachricht kommt äh nochmal vom RKI. Ich habe mir mal so eine der Bulletins äh angeschaut, die sie
rausgeworfen haben am dritten Dezember ist das erschienen und da ist mal auch ein anderer Fokus
noch äh drin, außer nur der auf den Corona Virus, nämlich auch mal so einen Vergleich. Wie sich denn so andere.
Infektionskrankheiten eigentlich in diesem Jahr,
verteilt haben. Und da wird also KW eins bis KW achtundvierzig von zwanzig neunzehn und zwanzig zwanzig miteinander verglichen.
Eine angeschaut, das ist wahrscheinlich in jedem Bulletin immer äh aktuell äh drin, aber teilweise ist es dann doch schon ziemlich äh,
deutlich. Ein paar Zahlen vielleicht mal als Beispiel. Also wir haben ja Noro, Virus.
Roter Virus, das sind ja auch so zwei Quellgeister,
Da hatten wir bis zur KB achtundvierzig in,
zwanzig neunzehn fast siebzigtausend Fälle,
in zwanzigzwanzig, also beim Norovirus sind es irgendwie knapp achtundzwanzigtausend Fälle, also deutlich weniger als die Hälfte. Bei dem Rothaar-Virus ist es äh das Verhältnis ungefähr sechsunddreißigtausend zu sechstausend, also Faktor sech,
dabei, ne? Also ganz deutlich, Hände waschen, Abstand halten und so weiter, das äh hilft auf jeden Fall.
Es gibt auch Rückgänge, die es nicht ganz so dramatisch sind bei so Sachen wie Hip
Titis, A, Hepatitis, B, also äh das ist jetzt vielleicht der Rückgang eher so um zwanzig Prozent. Patitis C, aber auch da eine relativ deutliche
Rückgangszahl
auch sowas wie Tuberkulose zum Beispiel, wobei ich jetzt nicht so richtig weiß, ob das äh Dinge sind, die jetzt die Leute sich hier wirklich in unserem Land holen.
Ja ja, ja, schon.
Ist das so? Allerdings Influencer.
Auch ist übrigens auch Süffeles Hotspot äh habe ich jetzt gehört.
Dann so äußere ich mich jetzt mal nicht. Ähm.
Aber Influencer Grippe, ja tatsächlich höhere Zahl.
Geringfügig, also hundertfünfundvierundneunzigtausendzwohundertneunzigtausend.
Aber damit hätte ich jetzt nicht unbedingt äh gerechnet. Paar andere Krankheiten allerdings gehen deutlich zurück. Masern.
Masern hatten wir in zwanzig neunzehn fünfhundertacht Fälle in den ersten achtundvierzig Wochen. In diesem Jahr fünfundsiebzig Fälle.
Äh
Was weiß ich, also Berlin zum Beispiel zweiundzwanzig Fälle im letzten Jahr jetzt drei so, ne? Also das ist ja auch so ein so ein Problem, dass die Masern wieder so am Aufkommen waren und
jetzt kann man das also dort deutlich sehen oder Mums
fünfhundertdreißig auf dreihundertdreiunddreißig Röteln von siebzehn Fälle auf sieben. Ist ja überhaupt ganz schön wenig,
staunlich, ne? Korchhusten, neuntausendfünfhundert auf dreitausenddreihundert runter. Ich runde das jetzt mal so ein bisschen ab hier. Äh Windpocken,
gut die Hälfte von zwanzig einundzwanzigtausend auf zehneinhalb. Also man sieht schon,
eine Änderung, warum das jetzt bei der Grippe immer noch vergleichbare Zahlen sind, vermag ich nicht zu beurteilen.
Vielleicht weil da weiß ich nicht durch das erhöhte Screening oder so.
Man vielleicht vorher nicht so viele Fälle gefunden hat, keine Ahnung. Also das äh kann ich nicht,
urteilen, aber man kann unterm Strich einfach festhalten, nimmt's ab, ne.
In Influencer ist praktisch gleich geblieben, kann man sagen, also geringer Zugang Zunahme, um also nicht drei Prozent oder so, das ist.
Sagen fast unterhalb der Messgenauigkeit. Aber das ist in der Tat, das ist interessant, dass sie Influencer gleichgeblieben ist, ja, dass würde ich gerne mal hören.
Bestimmt irgendeine interessante Erklärung, warum die Zahlen an sich äh wackelig sind. So, aber.
Ja, dann äh habe ich noch ein bisschen äh ins Internet geguckt für euch, nachdem ich hier letzte Woche den Vortrag von diesem österreichischen äh Virologen empfohlen habe.
Der mittlerweile auch, glaube ich, vom NDR Info im Podcast irgendwo gelandet ist, habe ich mir aber noch nicht angehört, die Sendung. Ähm habe ich mir noch ein paar andere Sachen angeschaut, die ich euch einfach mal empfehlen kann.
Und da gehört auf jeden Fall dazu ein Vortrag von Andrea Torn mit TH,
könnte auch Foren sagen, weiß nicht genau, ob das irgendwie ein englischer Name ist. Ähm und äh ich habe.
Hat sie sich schon ein bisschen länger aufm Kiker, hatte das aber hier nie so richtig untergebracht. Sie hat zusammen mit äh Kollegen,
relativ früh in diesem Jahr eine Corona Virus Tructural Task Force gegründet. Ähm.
Das ist sozusagen eine Gruppe, also sie ist äh Wissenschaftlerin und,
Sie beschäftigt sich mit so Strukturmodellierung von Molekülen und Proteinen und äh so etwas, ne. Das ist äh auch nochmal so ein, so eine, so eine besondere Begabung in diesem Feld
weiß ich nicht so richtig viel da drüber, diese Corona Virus Rachel Card Tasforce hat sich aber quasi in die in den Dienst gestellt für diese ganzen Forschungsgruppen
Weil ja diese Visualisierung, darüber haben wir ja letzte Folge auch nochmal ausführlich gesprochen, diese Durchbrüche mit Alpha Fold und Google und weiter bei der Visualisierung von von Protein äh Molekülen
weil das sozusagen,
wichtige Daten liefert für Angriffspunkte von Medikamenten und in diesem Fall natürlich vor allem Impfstoffe äh oder eben auch Medikamente für äh die Bekämpfung von Covit neunzehn.
Ja, ähm, der Vortrag ist äh verlinkt.
Also in dem Vortrag wird so nochmal gezeigt, wie wie groß wie die Größenverhältnisse eigentlich sind
ja? Also man muss sich klar machen, so ein Virus ist äh einfach kleiner als die Wellenlänge.
Da muss man also schon zu einem Elektronenmikroskop greifen, zeigt auch ein paar schöne
Bilder und von von diesem Virus wie also tatsächlich aussieht,
Und äh gibt dann auch nochmal so ein Roundup darüber, wie denn das eigentlich so äh aussieht und welche Molekülstrukturen
ist sozusagen darin gibt, dass es Virus hat irgendwie insgesamt achtundzwanzig verschiedene Proteine, davon ist ja das eine dieses Bike-Protein, das was so besonders interessant ist
und diese ganzen Strukturen in diesem Korona Virus, äh diese ganzen Molekülstrukturen, die sich daraus äh ergeben. Davon sind irgendwie.
Achthundertsechzehn bereits äh,
bekannt. Also das ist sozusagen nicht nur jetzt rein, diese Proteine, sondern die haben dann auch alle noch verschiedene Zustände und so weiter und ähm,
Sie zeigt halt so, mit welchen,
Methoden, dass äh normalerweise gemacht wird, da gibt's ja so Technik wie Röntgen, Christallographie und äh Nuklear, Magnetresonanz äh und auch die von mir letzte Woche erwähnte Kryotherapie,
Elektronenmikroskopie, also ne, wo man dann sozusagen einfach mal genau drauf schauen kann, äh was ist denn da jetzt eigentlich drin.
Und äh dann meinte sie noch, dass diese populäre tausendmal schon gesehene Visualisierung des Virus, ja, kennst du ja sicherlich auch, so diese,
Das ist äh tatsächlich eine sehr recht frühe Visualisierung, die auf Saß eins basiert,
Und die sie aber jetzt mittlerweile komplett neu gemacht haben und zeigt dann auch eine entsprechende Visualisierung, wie sie denken, wie dieses Virus äh äh tatsächlich aussieht, wenn man so nah überhaupt rankommt.
Ja, du meinst also wir haben alle jetzt so eher von den ganzen Bildern aus den Medien eigentlich das saß eins Virus im Kopf und gar nicht das saß zwei.
Genau, wobei die Unterschiede sind äh im Wesentlichen zu vernachlässigen, also die Unterschiede sind einerseits, dass äh das Ding wohl nicht ganz so rund ist
so ein bisschen eierig
dass dieses Bike-Proteine nicht so direkt da drauf kleben, sondern nochmal einen etwas deutlicheren,
äh haben, also so etwas weiter nach oben zeigen im Verhältnis und ähm,
dass auch dieses Bike-Proteine nicht so an so einer festen Position sind.
Sondern mehr oder weniger so auf dieser Oberfläche so ein bisschen herum äh schwimmen und von daher auch nicht so gleichmäßig verteilt sind,
ne? Das äh ja also ein Virus hat so ungefähr hundert Spikes und ja, dann zeigt sie also noch sehr schön,
auch die Effekte von Seife, ja, also warum Seife das aufbricht und wie es das auch tut, also diese diese Schutzhülle, um diese MRNA herum, diese Lipidhülle,
Fetthülle, die die wird ja von Seife angegriffen und äh sie zeigt auch nochmal genau, wie es funktioniert und da wird einem auch schnell klar, warum man auch
länger als zwanzig Sekunden lang seine Hände waschen sollte, damit's eben auch wirklich diesen gewünschten äh,
Effekt hat. Und was ich auch noch sehr schön fand, dass sie also auch noch so eine konkrete Visualisierung und zwar nicht so eine Showvisualisierung, sondern sie hat extra nochmal darauf hingewiesen, dass während tatsächlich jetzt die Visualisierung, die ihre die quasi das
unmittelbare wissenschaftliche Objekt sind, mit dem sie arbeiten. Also sie haben da wirklich solche äh also Animationen, wie.
Alles sich sozusagen bewegt und sie zeigt konkret den Moment,
Wenn sich das Virus mit der Zellmembran verbindet, das war für mich auch immer so ein bisschen so ein Rätsel, ne? Das wurde immer gesagt, so ja, das Bike-Protein und so wie äh das dockt dann da an, ja?
ACE zwei Rezeptoren und dann geht es so in die Zelle rein und das das stand immer so ein bisschen im Raum und ich hab mich immer gefragt so ja okay.
Aber wie, also ich meine, was heißt denn das andocken? Das ist so Klingel äh äh Drück
und dann geht die Tür auf oder was, so also wie kommt denn da rein ne,
in ihren Visualisierungen sieht man halt genau, wie das funktioniert, also wie dieses,
an diesem Rezeptor daran gehen,
sozusagen verbinden und dann gibt es noch so andere ähm,
Proteine vermutlich sind das die da rumlungern und die dann da so ein Schnitt vornehmen.
Ja, also die aus diesem Spike-Protein sowas wegschneiden und dann klappt das irgendwie alles auseinander und dann siehst du so richtig so eine mechanische äh Bewegung wie
von der Zelle dieses Virus rangezogen wird und wie sich diese Höhlen miteinander verbinden. Also ich fand das irgendwie total mein Bloging und äh das auf jeden Fall ein schöner Vortrag, den man sich mal
anschauen kann, den Link findet ihr in den Shownotes auf UKW Punkt FM.
Ja und einen zweiten verlinke ich auch noch, der ist jetzt nicht ganz so ähm.
Wie soll ich sagen, Zuhörer dieser Sendung wissen das alles schon, aber das ist von aus dem Paul Scherer Institut der Schweiz ein äh Wissenschaftler, der in so einem sechs Minuten Vortragsrelativ knapp
einmal so alles zusammenfasst, was derzeit so über diese Fragestellung mit äh Virus und Erosole äh zu wissen ist
So, also da ist mal einmal schön kompakt zusammengefasst äh so die aktuellen Größenordnungen, mit denen man's hier zu tun hat. Also äh wie groß sind Erosole, wie viel Viren sind da tatsächlich äh drin, ja?
Spoiler null Komma eins bis eins im Schnitt in zehn Mikrometer Erosol.
Und ja, also das mal so genau die ganzen Zahlen auflegt, so dass man so tausend Kopien, hundert bis tausend Kopien von dem Virus braucht, um fünfzig Prozent ein Funktionswahrscheinlichkeit haben, äh wie viel Erosole man produziert, wenn man spricht und wie viel Liter Atemluft sozusagen ausreichen für eine Infektion, ne?
Ähm ähm,
Kann ja auch gleich sagen, ein Liter Atemluft äh reicht aus, das sind so ein bis zwei Atemzüge äh und das könnte halt reichen für eine Infektion. So.
Sprich, das kann ganz schön schnell gehen.
Fast dann nochmal alle Maßnahmen äh zusammen, die aus dieser ganzen Perspektive heraus helfen, also draußen sein, Maske tragen, äh Luft mit Außenluft, stark äh verdünnen
CO zwei Monitore benutzen als guten Indikator für die Luftqualität
Hipa-Filtereinsätzen sind äh hilfreich. UVC-Licht ist hilfreich und halt fünfzig Prozent Luftfeuchtigkeit, das haben wir ja alles schon mal,
aber auch da findet man das schön kompakt in einem kleinen Video, in dem man sich das nochmal auffrischen kann. Ja und dann weiß man mehr.
Ja, das war's dann eigentlich ähm so,
von mir und damit sind wir dann auch so schon ein bisschen,
Ende angekommen dieser Sendung würde ich sagen, oder? Pavel. Noch irgendwas.
Ja, mir fällt gerade äh auch nichts ein. Ich stehe auch noch ein bisschen unter Schock äh irgendwie von den ja.
Was von den Daten.
Dann er ja dass sich das alles jetzt.
Auf einmal so schnell wieder.
Abhebt, äh, hatte ich jetzt nicht erwartet, ich hatte,
erwartet, dass das so so ein bisschen bisschen langsamer,
äh äh nach nach oben geht, aber äh wir haben halt richtig.
Ja wieder einen einen Start, also die Kurve, wenn man sich die, wenn man sich die anguckt.
Unterscheidet sich in ihrer Steigung jetzt nicht allzu sehr von der Kurve.
Haben sich alle auf November eingestellt. November ist vorbei. Also zehn Plus Ceature ist last hier, Mist, Sofie und dann geht sie halt wieder ab, die wilde Fahrt. Also.
Bleibt uns nichts anderes zu sagen, als äh,
Wenn ihr könnt, haltet euch raus aus dem Geschehen, denn dieses Geschehen ist mit viel zu viel Virus durchsetzt und da wollt ihr einfach nicht in der Wolke stehen.
Vielleicht ja eine Sache fällt mir noch ein äh auf die ich gestoßen.
Bin, das ist jetzt einen Paper, äh wo dann.
Untersucht wurde, wie denn bei Kindern sich halt Kowit-Infektionen eigentlich.
Auswirken so Langzeitmäßig und das war beunruhigend äh so. Also da ähm,
war in der äh Studie zu lesen, dass ungefähr die Hälfte der Kinder, die Kurve durchgemacht haben, selbst wenn sie.
Keine Symptome äh gezeigt haben, dann.
Ja, Schäden, Gefäßschäden davon,
getragen haben. Es war noch unklar, ob das wieder weggeht im Laufe der Zeit, aber äh das hat wohl bei ja bei der Hälfte der Kinder sogenannte Mikroembolin,
ausgelöst, so die dann quasi mein Kind,
dass aus anderen Bereichen mit den Mikroemboline und das ist wohl nicht gut,
ist jetzt eine Studie, ich habe mir die auch nicht,
äh im im Detail angeguckt und da muss sicherlich mehr kommen, um jetzt in Panik zu verfallen, aber ich fand das halt deswegen wichtig, zumindest ist es ein weiteres Indiz,
dass äh
ja dass das auch für Kinder nicht ungefährlich ist äh diese Erkrankung, dass man zumindest, also ich sehe auch keine,
Beweise, die jetzt sagen, okay, das ist jetzt für Kinder komplet,
schädlich da, wie auch keine Studien gesehen und solange es da keine Studien gibt
bin ich der Meinung, sollte man Kinder eigentlich genauso gut schützen, wie Erwachsene,
das scheint aber auch nicht der Fall zu sein, beziehungsweise hat sich das Gefühl in der Politik so ein bisschen auch durchgesetzt, daher die Kinder, die überleben das schon, die haben.
Darf zwei Tage Fieber und gut ist aber,
ja das ist auch nicht wirklich wissenschaftlich zu behaupten irgendwie.
Wir können die Kinder ruhig durchinfizieren so bei denen ist das nicht so schlimm.
Zumindest würde ich gerne in Frage gestellt.
Also haltet euch raus aus dem ganzen äh Geschehen. Ja, wir leben's euch vor und ihr macht einfach alle mit und dann wird wieder alles gut. Okay, dann machen wir einen Deckel drauf. Vielen Dank fürs Zuhören.
Und wir sagen tschüss und bis bald.
Tschüss, macht.